Hey guys,
Dave Rubin here.
That's right.
I'm still a Dave Rubin.
This is Rubin report.
As you guys know,
we are making the move to Aura TV.
They are building meet an.
An unbelievable set right now,
so Larry King was nice enough to let me
use his studio today and the reason we
wanted to do some stuff with you guys
today is because I have Dr.
Gad Saad here.
He is,
professor of marketing at Concordia
University in Montreal,
Canada and he's the research chair in
evolutionary behavioral sciences and
Darwinian consumption.
I normally don't use a teleprompter,
but I needed it for that get.
How are you?
Very good.
Yourself?
Good.
How?
First off Gad said,
how is my pronunciation of your last
name is Arabic and Arabic as well?
God is a Hebrew name and sad as an
Arabic name,
but most people can't say the guttural
sounds and so it just gets an extended
ace.
I'm sad.
Well,
I've heard you do it on your own videos
on youtube and you don't even do it with
the guttural sound because I don't want
to intimidate the viewers.
That sound so a Hebrew first name Arabic
last night.
That's right.
So you must be very conflicted.
I'm not,
I'm not.
I'm from Lebanon,
but of the Jewish faith.
Okay.
So the reason that I wanted to bring you
in and the timing of this really is just
perfect,
uh,
is because we connected sort of in the
last year and a half or so on twitter.
We find ourselves often in the same
twitter wars with people,
uh,
the atheists and the new atheists and
the far left and the people on the
right.
And everyone that's always battling on
twitter and we're usually on the same
side.
Right?
And really what started this whole thing
was when Sam Harris was on real time
with Bill Maher and he and Ben Affleck
and bill got into a big frack is a.
So let's take a look at the clip and
then we'll go from there.
Sure.
So the other thing,
we want to talk about the courses that
you and I have been trying to make the
case.
I think I have any way that liberals
need to stand up for liberal principles.
This is what I stood on last week's
show.
Obviously I got a lot of hate for it,
but all I'm saying is that liberal
principles like freedom of speech,
freedom to practice any religion you
want without fear of violence,
freedom to leave a religion,
equality for women,
a quality for minorities,
including homosexuals.
These are bit
principles,
applaud for,
but then when you done
say in the Muslim world,
this is what's lacking,
then they get upset.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
liberals have really failed on the topic
of theocracy that they'll criticize
white theocracy.
They'll criticize Christians,
they'll still get agitated over the
abortion clinic bombing that happened in
1984,
but when,
when you want to talk about the
treatment of women and homosexuals and
free thinkers and public intellectuals
in the Muslim world,
I would argue that the liberals have
failed us and the crucial point
confusion.
Yeah.
Thank God you're here.
I mean,
the crucial point of confusion is is
that that we have been sold this meme of
Islamophobia where every criticism of
the doctrine of Islam gets conflated
with bigotry toward Muslims as people.
That is intellectually ridiculous.
Even.
It gets so hold on who that person who
understands the officially codified
doctrine of Islam.
You say,
well,
this is actually well educated on this
topic.
I'm asking you.
You're saying if I criticize the.
You're saying that Islamophobia is not a
real thing,
that if you're critical of something,
it's not a real thing when we do it.
Right.
It's really is.
I'm not denying that that certain people
are bigoted against Muslims as people
and that's a problem big have you.
But the gross,
it's racist and it's not.
It's but it's so.
It's.
So.
It's like saying those years shifty.
You're absolutely not.
We are saying you guys are saying if you
want to be liberals believe in liberal
principles,
rights,
freedom of speech,
like you know,
we are endowed by our forefathers of the
low trek.
All men are created new fan.
We have to be able to criticize bad
ideas.
Okay,
so that clip goes on for about 10
minutes and I showed you about two
minutes right there and I think Sam hit
the point right at the end that we have
to be able to criticize bad ideas.
And to me this,
I've seen a real schism and people on
the left,
now I'm obviously on the left,
I stand for liberal principles,
um,
but this schism and this idea that you
can't criticize ideas without somehow
condemning a whole group of people.
I know this is a big point of contention
for you.
So can you walk us through that?
But I don't,
I don't think that people have
difficulty criticizing ideas.
I think it's a specific idea,
right?
So I see it everyday in my exchanges on
facebook.
If I criticize some Jewish practice,
I get many,
many likes on facebook.
If I criticize some Hick,
a Republican senator about his,
his position on evolution,
I get tons of likes.
But if I dare criticize something about
Islam,
I'll give you a very quick example.
I put up a clip of a Iraqi scientist,
an astronomer who was arguing that the
earth is flat because it says so in the
Koran.
So I received,
of course,
one of my facebook friends are academics
I received from a white sort of guilt
within academic from,
from California.
And a note saying,
well,
how,
what,
why are you ganging up on these folks?
So she wasn't offended by the fact that
this Iraqi scientists was holding an
astonishingly outrageous view.
She was annoyed that I would actually
point to that.
So why do you think people have trouble
making this distinction?
It's very obvious to me as as an
outsider of this.
I look at,
I'm Jewish,
but I look at the book,
you can say whatever you want about the
book and all the awful things that are
in the Old Testament and the new
testament or the Koran.
Frankly,
I haven't really read any of them.
I don't know their,
their books,
their ideas.
Why?
Why do people seem unable to detach
those two things because I think
they're.
I think the,
the misinformation associated with the
idea that if you criticize Islam in
particular,
you're bigoted because Islam is a
religion of Brown people and so
therefore there are simply unable to
decouple the criticism of a set of
tenets from the people who may practice
those tenets.
So to me,
Bill Maher sorta hit the maybe the
bigger point here,
which is that for people on the left,
for liberals,
we have to stand up consistently for
liberal principles,
which is certainly what I try to do.
I stand up for women's rights and gay
rights and freedom of religion and
economic equality and all of those
things.
So it was this weird,
liberals have really failed and the way
they fail is by invoking cultural and
moral relativism,
right?
So who are we to judge that?
Women in some far away land there
Clarissa's are being cut,
right?
Who are we to impose our cultural
hegemony on other folks?
And so that's how they're able to still
be liberal and yet not criticize these
one particular sets of beliefs by
invoking cultural relativism.
Right?
So there's a real disconnect in reality
there because in a,
in a weird way,
liberals should be the most for helping
these pieces on,
right?
Because these are the principles they
believe in.
So how much of this actually I really
hadn't thought until just now,
but I guess a lot of this we could sort
of blame the footsteps of George W Bush
for going into the wrong war.
We're now,
there's this feeling in America like we
shouldn't do anything ever because we
did the wrong thing.
Clearly interacting now it's a,
it's a far worse mess than even before.
Uh,
so some of the blame is on us,
right?
But I mean,
how far do you go back unfolding history
until you find the villain of your
choice?
Right?
So for example,
when you talk about the Israel Palestine
issue,
people are always able to unfold history
until the starting point that they feel
happy about.
And then that's the point where we start
the clock,
right?
So where should we start the clock on
that one?
On the Islam issue in Israel.
Palestine.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's a whole other thing.
It's a whole lot of effect if we could
get into it if you want.
Uh,
uh,
I think the problem there is that you've
got to abrahamic religions that hold
very,
very rigid positions.
And as long as it's going to be les than
would religion,
it's never going to be resolved.
So in a weird way.
So what you're saying is that,
uh,
that liberals don't want to criticize
Islam because there's this idea that a
lot of Islamic people have brown skin,
but there are plenty of Moroccan Jews.
You're,
you're Lebanese Jew,
right?
Uh,
there are plenty of Christians that are
Iraqi.
There's not that many anymore.
But.
So even that,
in a weird way you could say that that's
actually bigoted,
that,
that concept is big.
And how do you,
as,
as a dark skinned a Jew you feel about
that?
Well,
I usually am able to get away with more
stuff precisely because I invoke the
fact that I have dark skin.
The fact that I'm from the Middle East
and I,
I use this victimology game against the
social justice warriors basically
saying,
Hey,
be careful,
don't you criticize me?
Because then you'd be engaging our
football,
our phobia,
fattism.
I actually did the privilege score and I
scored off the chart and my non
privilege.
So I'm untouchable.
You were completely unimaginable.
So the next part of this that I think is
particularly interesting,
and this is really where we met because
of the twitter thing that I referenced
earlier,
is there has been sort of an endless
onslaught on Sam Harris since this.
Now.
Sam is a philosopher.
I think he's a neuroscientist.
I've read this.
I've read some books.
He's not a political person per se.
He writes a little bit about politics,
but not really,
but there has been this endless
onslaught and I think slandering and
smearing him,
coming from the left from people that in
some cases I admire partly some people
that I've worked with,
I'm talking about from,
from Glenn Greenwald,
who obviously has done great stuff with
the NSA and Reza Aslan,
my former boss,
Janky younger people that are really
distorting his views.
And I wanted to show a tweet that I got
last night that I think kind of sums up
the whole thing.
So let's,
let's take a look at the tweet.
Okay.
So this had nothing.
I wasn't tweeting about this.
This has nothing to do with anything.
And someone tweeted,
Zap me questioning for Ruben report,
how exactly are we better than Isis?
If we knew the Middle East killing
millions of civilians like Sam Harris
suggest.
And then Sam Harris later wrote back and
said,
you really believe that?
I've actually suggested that.
Okay,
so that tweet right there.
The reason I wanted to use it is because
I feel like it's a perfect example of
how this discussion that we're talking
about has been so far derail.
Now of course Sam Harris doesn't want to
nuke them in the Middle East.
He had one page in his book that's
mostly about philosophy and religion
where he's talking about how in the Cold
War we had a mutual assurance is
basically with Russia because you had
rational actors basically that wouldn't
nuke each other because then they were
afraid they were going to get new.
Now this has nothing to keep.
Never said nuke the Middle East or any
of this stuff,
but these people keep implying it.
They keep retweeting memes of selective
quotes.
What do you make of that?
I mean these.
These are pretty respected people.
Some that I know personally,
which is why I struggle with this so
much,
you know,
in the battle of ideologies that people
that you want to go after are not the
people who've got big muscles,
but the people who have big brains,
those are sort of totalitarian ideology.
Ideology is always go after the
intellectuals first.
They want to purge them because they
don't want anybody to counter their
narrative and so this is exactly what
happens to guys like Sam Harris.
He has a huge following that he can't be
literally beheaded because we don't live
in the Middle East,
but I could certainly try my darnedest
to be head his reputation and I'm going
to do that by engaging in endless miss
information so that people can distance
themselves from him and he's just a
crack.
He's a,
he's a warmonger,
he's a Nazi.
He's part of a Zionist conspiracy and
hopefully you'll kind.
Don't forget Neocon,
right?
That's new economy part of Halliburton
and so on and,
and,
and the way I behead him,
the way I silence him as by smearing
come.
Right?
So isn't that really the crazy part of
this?
When,
when they're saying,
well,
you know,
Sam Harris is in the same neo-con group,
or Bill Maher's and the same neo-con
group as Dick Cheney.
Bill Maher has never talked about all
the time he wants our,
we have 30,000
trench or something in Germany.
What are they doing there?
But this is literally the reverse of a
neo con.
Um,
but these,
these slurs,
these are slanders,
right?
Really,
I mean is that while these,
these false equivalences are everywhere
within this discourse.
So for example,
if you take some feminists,
they'll argue that,
uh,
the bikini is a patriarchal tool of
oppression.
Whereas the Burka is a liberating thing
because it removes the male gaze from
the picture,
right?
So while the Bikini clad women is being
visually raped by men,
uh,
once you,
once you don the burka,
she is liberated.
So these types of equivalencies are
astonishing,
but they're everywhere right now.
As backwards as I may think that is,
I would say,
you know what?
You can believe that if you want,
but it should be up to the woman to
decide where in most of those countries
where women are wearing burgers,
they don't really have the choice not to
wear.
Of course now I'm more critical at this
point and where I'm at of the left
because I'm part of the left and I want
the left to be better.
I've long given up on trying to fix the
right right here.
That's that know I'm not going to fix
the tea party,
but I can at least I think try to change
for the better.
The part that I'm with.
So that's why this is so disappointing.
What do you make of this idea that the,
that the far left is attacking atheists
have of all groups of people?
It's astonishing.
I mean what?
I guess one of the reasons why they
attacked the atheist is because they
might be some of the most philosophers,
a group of of people that are critical
of religion in general,
but Islam in particular,
and so to the extent that the
progressives don't like criticism of
Islam and to the extent that many of the
most famous atheists are quite
vociferous in their criticism of Islam,
then we have to go after them and I
guess this goes back to what you were
saying earlier,
but they don't seem to be able to make
the distinction.
When Bill Maher relentlessly attacked
Christianity,
nobody calls him a Christian of.
Right,
right.
I mean he,
I,
he made a documentary where he attacked
the big three religions relentlessly.
Nobody had prompts.
So like the processing of information is
a big cognitive bias,
right?
So I will only pay attention to
information that supports my position
and that's exactly what the progressives
are doing.
They're ignoring the endless times that
bill Maher attacks other religions,
but they only tune in when he criticizes
Islam.
I would bet,
and someone can check this for us,
but I would bet that Bill Maher has
spent far more time attacking
Christianity because he attacks things
in this country far more than than
attacking Islam or Judaism or whatever.
What do you make of how much hatred
there seems to be towards atheists at
the moment because I see all these poles
and on the show,
many times we've done how atheists are
the most underrepresented group in
everything.
Barney frank,
who was in Congress for 30 something
years,
was able to come out as gay in the
eighties,
but not as an atheist until he retired
from Congress.
Right?
What do you make of this?
Because atheist hold no power.
Have not.
Our people are atheist,
killing people that I don't know about
my.
My feeling is that there is a coupling
of atheism and immorality in the minds
of most people,
so most people believe that.
It doesn't matter which religion you
follow,
as long as you are religious,
then you somehow have a moral compass by
which you live your life.
By however atheists go around beheading
and then raping them for in the minds of
those folks.
And so an atheist is not to be trusted
because how else working he get his
morality if it's not from some Bronze
Age book.
So I think what you just told me that
it's complete nonsense.
It is complete.
Unless I mean it,
could it be anything other than that,
right?
I mean,
because atheist simply aren't doing any
other things.
No,
it's good.
It's complete lunacy political
correctness,
which I think is completely running
rampant across America right now.
I live within it as an academic,
as an academic,
so we're going to swim in it,
so,
you know.
All right,
so let's start there then.
So to the college part of this,
uh,
you know Jerry Seinfeld about a month
ago.
Jerry Seinfeld,
who is the most apolitical comic.
Yes.
I know everything about Jerry Seinfeld.
I don't know any of his political
beliefs.
I have no idea if he's for abortion,
for the death penalty.
Nobody has any idea what he thinks he
now is saying the college campuses have
gone too politically correct.
Politically correct.
Chris Rock has backed him on this.
Um,
you know,
a whole bunch of comedians have said
this,
what is going on on college campuses.
I'll give you a powerful personal
anecdote.
A last year I gave a talk at Wellesley
college and all women's college about
the thought police and how it regulates
the free exchange of ideas.
After my lecture,
a student came up to me and said,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with the idea of a professor at the
start of class pulling 100 students
about how you should address them.
So even though,
for example,
Dave Rubin is my student,
I clearly see you as a male at the start
of every lecture I should say,
do you do gender identify as male or
female because that will deter.
So I looked at her and in true
astonishment I said,
do you really see this as a viable way
by which society would be organized?
Where every single time we interact we
should first preempt any,
any greeting with what do you self
identify as?
And she said,
absolutely,
because that way you wouldn't be hurting
anybody by placing them in the wrong
category.
That's astonishing.
Right.
Okay.
So what's the most dangerous part of
that?
Because to me it seems like,
let's say you went ahead and did that.
You taught this class exactly as sort of
the social justice warriors would want
you to teach it.
Well the world doesn't operate like
that.
Right?
So then are you actually then setting up
these kids,
these college kids for a huge awakening
where the day they graduate college,
but they're not well trained to face
that real world,
right.
There are so tentative and the way they
express themselves,
right?
They're so afraid to step outside the
herd.
I mean if you look at intellectual
diversity on campuses,
which is very much related to what we're
talking about,
it's breathtaking.
Right?
Look,
I'm Canadian so I don't care.
Republican or Democrat.
I don't have a dog in that fight,
but there are.
I got to get this straight.
Jus Heron,
Canadian man,
atheists,
atheists and brown skin.
Oh my gosh.
You really do have a lot.
All right.
Sorry.
So,
so there,
there were studies that were done
looking at the political affiliations of
professors at Major American
universities,
whether they're republican or Democrat,
and the numbers are just astonishing and
they get worse and worse in terms of the
ratio as a function of the softness of
the field.
So in the humanities and sociology and
gender studies,
it's something like 40 1:44
to one ratio of.
Now for some issues,
political,
a political lens doesn't matter,
but for others,
uh,
as the death penalty appropriate,
what should be our fiscal policy?
Should we be?
Should we be foreign policy
interventionists?
Well,
your political lens effects these
discussions and to have all academia
being represented by one side of the
political spectrum as horrifying.
So what do we do about that?
I mean,
even though I may in most cases agree
with that end of academia,
not certainly not the political correct
side,
but I might agree with him
philosophically on a lot of the points.
How do you balance that out?
So Thomas Solo,
who's a very famous conservative
economists,
a set,
and I'm going to botch the exact quote,
he said,
a intellectual diversity is diversity on
campuses as great as long as it's sexual
orientation,
diversity,
ethnic diversity,
racial diversity,
but the one diversity that should really
matter,
intellectual diversity,
we condemn it.
Well,
what we need to do is just a thought,
which is thought exactly.
And what we need to.
It was to find ways to create greater
diversity on campus is to allow both
sides of any position to speak.
Do you think a lot of this has to do
with the way our culture has changed in
the last couple of years?
Like where are you can't bully a kid
now.
I'm not for bullying of course,
but that this concept where we keep
making everything that no one can ever
be offended by anything else.
Uh,
you know,
they took after the confederate flag,
after the shooting in Charleston.
Now they took dukes of hazzard off
television.
Do.
Those guys were not,
they were not somehow southern white
supremacists.
You know what I mean?
But they,
they took that off television.
Again,
I'm not going to defend cosby who was
one of my comedy heroes growing up,
but they took the cosby show up.
They're like,
we're starting to censor ourselves.
I think in a way that's going to lead to
everything.
You know,
every time I watched Seinfeld now,
every episode,
I think in 10 years they're gonna say
this was racist and massage every
literally every single episode.
Salon did a piece a couple of weeks ago
about trouble.
Some episodes,
episodes of Seinfeld.
What?
What do we do to combat that?
Well,
progressive's pray at the altar.
They self flagellate at the altar of non
offense.
I mean that's,
that's their,
their motto.
A,
we need to find a way to break through
this thought.
Police.
I'm not.
Give you an example.
When I used to be a very competitive
soccer player,
if I were to today,
look at the trash talking that went on
the soccer fields between players,
which is part of the ritual.
Then everybody would be arrested today.
Everybody would be sent to a hate
speech.
Try again.
Right?
Because you mean because of racist stuff
and homophobic on everything under the
sun.
Exactly,
guess what I heard camel jockey grow
growing up playing soccer and I lived
to,
to love again,
right?
I mean it's called life grow a pair.
So,
so how do we,
what do we do about that because that I
really like what do we do to grow a pair
for the country or for Canada or.
I mean there are many different ways.
For example,
uh,
the culture of narcissism is,
it's certainly not helping the kids.
The culture of entitlement,
right?
Everybody should get an a plus.
Everybody should get their medal.
Everybody should get a trophy.
So there,
there's several different movements that
have,
for lack of a better word,
pussified the west.
You're not going to be happy with you
for that if that's okay.
Bring.
All right,
let's talk a little bit about some of
the,
uh,
some of the machinations I suppose,
of,
of things that are going on on college,
trigger warnings and some of these other
things.
So you were sort of,
you sort of talked about this a little
bit earlier.
Safe spaces,
safe spaces,
safe spaces is a place where I can go so
that I'm protected from things that
might make me go into a fetal position
and suck my thumb.
So give me one for example.
Well,
why would you go to a site?
Why would someone in college go to it?
Maybe there's going to be a speaker
who's going to talk something about pro
Israel and uh,
I might be a student who is very much
against Israel.
And so that makes me feel very
threatened at University of Michigan.
They wanted to simply show,
was it,
was it called sniper?
What was it?
The movie American sniper.
And that made a lot of the students feel
very unsafe simply because that movie
was going to be shown on campus.
It's astonishing.
Do you remember when,
uh,
Bill Maher was being asked to give the
commencement speech at Berkeley,
Berkeley,
which is the bastion,
the home of free speech in America.
And some of the kids there didn't want
him to do it.
He ended up doing it,
but he had a guest.
I forget her name.
I was actually in the audience that
episode.
He had a guest who said that he
shouldn't do it because he's against
free speech.
Meanwhile,
she's on her.
She's on his show using her right to
free speech.
So there's like a a cognitive
disconnect.
There's absolutely.
I wrote an article where I have
Huffington post where I talked about
trigger warnings and I listed all of the
different concepts that necessitate
trigger warnings pretty much everything
under the sun.
I mean,
literally life requires a trigger
warning.
Is this why everyone's medicated?
Pretty much,
right?
I think you're onto something.
You know,
I do think there is a connection
between,
you know,
if you do all this stuff right and you
give every year,
everyone is the trigger warnings.
You give them safe spaces.
You don't let them hear from contrarian
views and all this stuff.
Then you throw them out in the world
where none of this stuff is real because
you get out to the world and it's pretty
shitty and you're know you're going to
have a boss that might be sexist or a
neighbor that might be homophobic.
That is why then everyone,
Medicaid's because then they're not
given the tools to deal in reality life.
I agree.
How's that?
Behavioral Sciences.
That's rather nice.
Pop Psychology.
Very nice.
I thought that was pretty good.
Do you think the Internet is helping or
hurting?
A bit of both.
I mean,
I think to the extent that the Internet
serves as a vehicle for meme
propagation,
people can get their message out,
otherwise they might have difficulty
doing so.
So in that sense it's great.
The problem is that some of the ones who
hurled the greatest amount of venom are
the people who really are against the
free exchange of ideas.
So the social justice warriors that come
after guys.
Luckily I've actually been free of most
of these guys maybe because I'm quite
reserved than my positions.
Maybe.
Hopefully,
uh,
but,
but make sure they come after yesterday.
I'll send some of my people.
So I think that on average a bit of both
good in that you allow people to express
themselves bad and that there's one camp
of folks that is a lot more vested in
shutting down free exchange.
So is that the challenge then of the
atheist community or the secular
community or the rational community is
that we don't yell as loud,
right?
So how do we then line up in a way
versus versus the trolls versus the
angry mob?
How do you get sane people to band
together?
Well,
at the very least,
and I often a admonish my academic
colleagues for this who don't
participate in this and this great
public discourse,
right?
They're very interested in doing.
They're very narrow research,
but yet they are shy away from talking
about these bigger issues.
Even though their professors.
I mean you're,
you're all about meme propagation if
you're a professor.
And so what I would do,
at least what I do at my limited sphere
of influence,
is to try to get my colleagues to weigh
in on these issues so that we could have
academics weighing in and not just the
trolls.
Does that work very well?
I haven't been very successful because
most are terrified of their shadows.
Yeah.
So what does that say then?
That it's not just.
I guess it's coming from every angle,
right?
It's coming from politicians and it's
coming from the media people and it's
coming from the professors,
not just what I would add.
I would add cowardice as part of the
seven deadly sins.
I would make it a deadly sins and
cowardice.
It's,
I'm astonished at how cowardly,
uh,
most people are there and I even get
people who come to me and say,
you know,
I mean,
you,
you do great science.
You're,
you're,
you're a non scientist.
Why do you weigh in on these issues?
Because I can't help it because it's,
I feel that it's my job to weigh in on
issues that are nonsensical.
Like the ones we discussed earlier.
That's part of my job description.
Yeah.
You know,
I feel the same way actually.
Sometimes I think when I'm,
when I'm tweeting about this stuff or
when I'm writing about or whatever it
is,
I think I wish I didn't have the right
to talk about this stuff.
You know,
in a weird way because it's so obvious
to me.
Uh,
you know,
that the atheist and the seculars that
we're,
we're on the right side of letting
everyone.
I want to treat everyone as Shitty as
everyone else.
They don't even have to be treated as
well as everyone else.
You know what I mean?
I don't want to be treated better than
anyone or worse.
Just treat me the same shitty way you
treat everybody.
A lot of times when I'm in New York
City,
that's what I think.
Like everyone,
there's every race there,
there's every color,
every ethnicity,
everything,
and it's like everyone hates each other,
but no one's killing anybody pretty
much.
Exactly.
Any,
any final thoughts?
I mean,
I could talk to you all day.
Uh,
well hopefully I'll be back again soon.
I wanted to congratulate you on your
move to this network.
Oh,
thanks.
Great to meet you in person.
And it's weird how twitter works,
right?
We've done this.
We've never spoken more than a hundred
40 characters and yet I feel like.
I know you're very well.
Yeah,
there you go.
All right,
well you guys can check out gads youtube
page.
We'll annotate to it.
So there should be something if you're
watching on youtube right over here.
And I thank you very much.
And uh,
yeah,
this is just the beginning of the types
of stuff we're going to be doing.
Now that we're on TV,
uh,
the new set is coming and the show will
officially launched.
I think it's the second week in
September,
but I'll have to check with my lawyers.
Thanks for watching everybody.